how's the compress my name is Pippa I'm
stuck in the middle of nowhere without a
vehicle what do I do
I know I can share the car
we go there ah I'm fine I'm fine
everyone has gay let's go to that
billboard ah such an awesome mod [ __ ]
love all the month this is why I waited
for DCA to come on on the [ __ ] PC run
run again you're a run [ __ ] oh oh well
you almost killed me have some God for
your environment oh look there's
gangsters in the hood well I got cars
[ __ ] can I hurt people
oh my god
I'm not
did you enjoy it
did you enjoy it I want to ride my
bicycle I want to ride my bike this
absolutely oh my god what happened
everyone gets a free car I'm Oprah [ __ ]
man it feels good to give you know
take this [ __ ] he likes it look at him
ah God all of it ah yeah that's how it's
done
now I'm taking over this train office
set up it's a train man stop the train
man
stop the damn train man oh well baby oh
I will
what's up it Jess what's up it Jess
that's what I'm talking about right
there hey how you doing lady
hey I'm cool yes yes
then give me a dance goddammit yes now
that's what I'm talking about oh my god
those are okay goddamn it I wasn't
touching guts foot foot
ass house oh you gonna pay for this [ __ ]
that's not how you treat your VIP
customers [ __ ] you looking at that's
what you
getta [ __ ] with a monkey that's our name
oh my god what happened
yep that's what happens any questions
chimpanzee away ten that there was a lot
of fun playing with you today hit that
like button it really helps out a lot I
appreciate it thank you both so much for
watching leave a comment about
chimpanzees ass and that's all I gotta
say for you stay awesome bros there you
are this is the greatest thing I'd ever
seen in my life what the [ __ ] is
happening I can't get out the sidewalk
yes